dans le reste de l'actualité la campagne
de vaccination bat son plein depuis
maintenant un mois et des communes ont
pris les choses en main pour faciliter
l'accès au centre pour les personnes
âgées c'est le cas à ballan-miré
première en indre et loire à mettre en
place un système de transports publics
gratuits pour ses seniors de 75 ans et
désireuses de se faire vacciner
aurélie renault avec romain delville à
81 ans est soigné d'un cancer philippe
guéneau fait partie de ces personnes
prioritaires pour avoir son rendez-vous
de vaccination il a multiplié les
connexions sur d'octo libre et ce ne fut
pas une mince affaire pour cet habitant
de ballan-miré j'avais une date en
février le 7 février au moment où je
clique est elle disparaît et il se
présente une une deux dates deux jours
le dise le 28 et le 29 janvier avec
trois horaires j'ai là je n'ai pas
attendu j'ai cliqué aussitôt mg après
bon beh tenait le bon bout quoi
encore faut-il se rendre au centre de
vaccination celui de monsieur guaino est
situé à l'espace clos n'a pas joué les
tours alors la municipalité de
ballan-miré propose à ses habitants un
système de mini bus à la demande
ce soir c'est un élu du conseil
municipal délégué aux sports qui va donc
emmener philippe guéneau sur la commune
de banne en irlande on a dénombré
environ 830 personnes qui ont 75 ans et
plus donc 830 personnes on s'est mis en
capacité de les transporter
mais ce que nous et notre notre premier
balannec l'on emmène avec grand plaisir
une fois arrivé sur place le retraité
rempli son questionnaire consultation
avec le médecin puis piqûre avec nadine
l'infirmière et comme pour tout nouveau
vaccin un quart d'heure d'attentes pour
s'assurer que la personne ne fait pas
une réaction cdh engagement personnel
parce que comme j'étais déjà malade
avant j'ai été opéré et où je trouvais
qu'il fallait mieux de vacciner que 2
d'attendre encore six mois ou des choses
comme ça parce que finalement on est
toujours sur le qui-vive en permanence
ce soir comme tous les soirs ce sera
potage de légumes un laitage et une
pomme pour monsieur keno prochain
rendez-vous pour sa deuxième injection
d'ici trois semaines
il demandera d'abord à sa fille de
l'emmener sinon ce sera la mairie